[Musique]
catherine laborde et à côté de l enfer
une météo très spécial vous avez une
oreillette winner iata jean marie bigard
qui est en régie et qui va vous parler
est un vrai veut dire tout ce qu'il dit
voilà c'est votre pc votre météo de
touche pas à mon poste d'accord vous
avez vraiment donné hier que je fais
tout ce qui est mis exactement vous dit
tout ce qu'il vous dit de faire pour le
moment
jean marie bigard est ce qu'il est
l'amant jean-marie oui genre alors on va
mettre la carte de la météorite à fabien
de l'être le producteur qui est à côté
le guingampais qu'on embrasse on
embrasse guingamp ne voit ça on embrasse
toute la bretagne
les chéris la météo et là vous pouvez
vous mettre à côté et je vais arriver on
appris auprès de météo sais pas si ma
chérie massif alors les mots jingle on
n'est pas ici c'est parti
c'est parti ou orgue mesdames
mesdemoiselles et surtout messieurs
bonsoir demain dans toute la france il
fera le show il fera très très chaud
hier un puceau que dans la culotte 2 qui
se reconnaîtra
la colle ce n'est pas pour rien n'est ce
pas quand l'allument l'allume-cigare
l'appel l'allume-cigare c'est promis je
vous en prie je ne traite pas de cauna
moi non mais autres actifs agro monde a
des tas de merde et bien voilà qui doit
on ou pc serait c'est la première fois
c'est pas bizarre de dire ça qu'ils vont
nous pisser sur la gueule
[Applaudissements]